un informe preocupante nunca el número
de refugiados y de desplazados en el
mundo había sido tan elevado la ONU ha
hecho las cuentas una cifra récord de
110 millones de personas se han visto
obligadas a abandonar sus hogares una
cifra que no deja de aumentar
Recuerda que hace unos años Incluso el
año pasado anunciamos por primera vez
que habíamos superado los 100 millones
de desplazados bien esa cifra ha
aumentado un 10%
es una verdadera acusación contra el
estado de nuestro mundo si se me permite
decirlo tener y anunciar eso la razón de
este fuerte aumento los conflictos en
particular el que afecta a Sudán los
enfrentamientos entre el ejército y los
paramilitares han disparado el número de
desplazados en las últimas semanas la
guerra en Ucrania también ha contribuido
a este aumento récord otra lección de
las Naciones Unidas
tres cuartos de estos refugiados huyen a
países de bajos ingresos esto contradice
la idea a menudo difundida sobre todo en
Europa de olas migratorias que
abrumarían a las naciones ricas el alto
comisionado para los refugiados ha
lanzado un mensaje a los dirigentes
políticos a menudo oímos la opinión
pública está harta no podemos aceptar a
nadie más gobernar también significa
convencer a la opinión pública de que
ciertas personas necesitan protección
internacional y de que hay que hacer
todo lo posible para conseguirlo
acnur también ha reconocido que no
dispone de los medios necesarios para
ayudar a esos millones de refugiados